anne innocent et il en prison depuis 15
ans peu à peu les indices s'accumulent
patrick dils a été condamné à la
perpétuité pour un double meurtre
d'enfants à montigny-lès-metz mais il
clame son innocence
aujourd'hui un rapport des gendarmes
confirment bien que le tueur en série
francis heaulme étaient sur place au
moment des faits la cour de cassation
devra se prononcer le 15 mars prochain
luc laguerre boucher francis pohlm
travailler dans une entreprise à 300
mètres des lieux du crime
ses collègues de travail se souviennent
que son comportement a brutalement
changé dès le lendemain du double
meurtre perpétré en septembre 86 et
francis heaulme n'a plus d'alibi sa
grand mère et un ami qui affirmait que
le tueur en série était à leurs côtés au
moment du crime
ces deux personnes ont démenti tous ces
éléments nouveaux sont le fruit du
travail de la gendarmerie de metz chargé
par la cour de cassation d'un supplément
d'information
des éléments qui renforcent la
conviction de la famille dils pour leur
fils patrick condamné à perpétuité en
1989 n'est pas coupable s'attendent à
prouver l'innocence de notre fille suis
fait de plus en plus à des éléments à
charge contrôle et il n'y en a pas à
charge contre notre fils maintenant il
faut que ça aille vite faut qu'à la cour
de cassation comme décisions plus
rapidement possible le 15 mars prochain
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation décidera si oui ou non la
condamnation de patrick 10 doit être
annulée si en l'état du dossier
il la cour estime qu'il n'y a pas
d'élément nouveau permettant de douter
culpabilité alors je crains qu'elle
n'est pas la même lecture de la langue
française que moi et vous seriez choqué
je ne serais pas choqué je serai anéanti
comme toute personne de bonne volonté
qui a vu lé de ces dix et qui sait
parfaitement y compris nombreux
magistrats que dit ces petits nos sens
et qu'il purge à la place d'un haut
depuis 14 ans pour un double crime qu'il
n'a pas commis
patrick dils sera bientôt fixée âgé de
16 ans au moment du double meurtre il
sera dans un mois
s'il a passé la moitié de sa vie
derrière des barreaux pour une erreur
judiciaire